optimal room like this altitude like a
non flat out for a half mile before my
hands start shaking so now I'm supposed
to flip now I'm a cybernetic organism
living tissue over metal endoskeleton
this podcast is brought to you by 4
Sigma tech I reached out to these
Finnish folks young entrepreneurs very
talented after a Acrobat introduced me
to one of their products which is
mushroom coffee this specific one
includes chaga and lion's mane and nut
my socks off I highly recommend if you
try it you start with half a packet it's
very strong and lights you up like a
Christmas tree in the best way possible
people are always asking me what I use
for cognitive enhancement and for right
now this is the answer I try to force
this on all of my houseguests it is a
hell of a thing if I have employees or
people come over who are working on
projects with me I always try to feed it
to them because I'm going to get the
limitless effect it gets a lot more out
of them the first time I mentioned this
product and for sig Matic on the podcast
their products sold out in less than a
week so you may want to check them out
soon if you're listening to this and the
coffee tastes like coffee
it takes just seconds to prepare with
hot water and oddly enough only includes
40 milligrams of caffeine so it has less
than half of what you would get in a
regular cup of coffee I don't get any
jitters as reflux or any stomach burn
any of that it's very unusual and very
very cool
so if you don't like caffeine they also
offer very strong but caffeine free
mushroom elixirs which I will sometimes
have in the evening I find chaga
specifically to be very very grounding
and earthy so that is another option and
I have a cupboard full of their products
at the moment which is right around the
corner of my kitchen you can try
something you can try a sample pack
which is great also right now by going
to four sig Matic calm forward slash Tim
that's four sig Matic fo you are SI g ma
TI c calm forward slash Tim and use the
code Tim
I am to get 20% off of your first order
and they're not that expensive anyway if
you are in the experimental mindset I do
not think you'll be disappointed so try
them this episode is brought to you by
audible which I've used for many many
years I absolutely love audiobooks and
they are one of my favorite ways to pass
the time when I travel I'm on the road
all the time and audible allows me to
consume many more books than I possibly
could otherwise I have two audio books
to recommend right off the bat the first
is perhaps my favorite audio book of all
time and it's the only audio book I've
wanted to listen to twice in a row the
graveyard book by Neil Gaiman it's
amazing and you will thank me there are
a few different versions
I like the version that Neal narrates
himself one of the most soothing voices
of all time the second book is
vagabonding by Rolf Potts P o T TS which
had a huge impact on my life and form
the basis for a lot of what would later
become the 4-hour workweek so go to
audible.com for word slash Tim and you
can choose one of these two books or any
of many many other options that could be
books magazines and much more as a
listener of the Tim Ferriss show you can
also access a free 30-day trial just go
to audible.com forward slash to him you
can't make more time but you can make
the most of it so turn your travel or
your commute into something more with a
free trial at audible.com forward slash
Tim to start now and get your free
30-day trial
hello ladies and germs this is Tim
Ferriss and welcome to another episode
of the Tim Ferriss show my dog Molly is
staring me directly in the face from
about three feet away but that is not
relevant to this particular introduction
the Tim Ferriss show what is it well my
job is every episode to deconstruct
world-class performers people who are
the best at what they do to give you
tactics routines habits etc that you can
apply immediately in tests in your own
lives this particular episode has been
requested and requested and requested
people ask me Tim why are you talking
about relationships when are you going
to talk about relationships why are you
so private why are you dodging the
questions will no longer folks I am
going to speak with Esther Perel I
wanted to speak with this particular
psychotherapist for many years and for
good reason she has been called the most
important game-changer in sexuality and
relational health since dr. Ruth by the
New York Times who featured her in a
cover story her TED talks one of which
she actually basically winged
off-the-cuff which is amazing to me her
talks on maintaining desire and
rethinking infidelity of more than 17
million views she's tested and been
exposed to everything imaginable in 34
years of running her private therapy
practice in New York City in this
episode we explore everything imaginable
we talk about her life story how to find
and convince mentors who can change your
life for instance what she's learned
from Holocaust survivors but then we get
into what she's very much known for we
discussed topics like polyamory and all
of its close cousins is there such a
thing as too much honesty in
relationships we answer or attempt to
answer questions like can we want what
we already have
why do happy people cheat and much much
more she has many many case studies
because she's been practicing this in
the real world and messy reality for so
long a little bit of background on
Esther who have had a chance to spend
time with in person now and is just more
impressive the more time I spend with
her she's the author of the
international bestseller mating in
captivity many of you have heard of this
it's been translated in 26 languages
she is fluent in nine of them I've heard
her in person do this in a crowded room
going from person to person in different
languages it blows my mind has a
language nut this Belgian native now
brings her multicultural pulse to a new
book the state of affairs and subtitle
rethinking infidelity which is out
October 2017 through HarperCollins right
now though well you can check out of
hers and you should check out is a brand
new audible original audio series where
should we begin
and she's co-creating this and hosting
it with audible and this looks at
specific couples and walks you through
their issues and how she would recommend
they address them so check that out
where should we begin you can say hello
to her on the socials at Facebook for
instance comm /s thoreau lper al but I
the blast with this it's going to expose
my my sensitive vulnerable underbelly
for those people who have been asking
for all this relationship stuff so feel
free to ridicule me on the Internet
usually don't even have to ask that just
comes with this job that I've created
for myself so without further ado please
enjoy this wide-ranging conversation
with Esther Perel Esther welcome to the
show thank you
hello I am thrilled to finally have
connected with you and you have one of
the hottest possible areas of expertise
imaginable and there's so many questions
that I would like to ask and so many
questions that my fans would like to ask
but I thought we could start with a bit
of background again if you could tell us
just a bit about where you grew up and
what your childhood was like I think
that'd be good is context to get us
started so I grew up in Antwerp in
Belgium mostly enter with the Flemish
part of Belgium and I was there till I
finished high school I grew up with I
have a big brother who's 12 years older
than me so I was the young girl and my
parents who were actually
Polish refugees who came to Belgium
after the war from Belgium I moved to
Jerusalem and I studied at Hebrew
University in Jerusalem and I lived
there for almost six years and then I
came to Cambridge Massachusetts to
finish my master's degree and and I
really thought I was coming for one year
to America but that one year became two
years in Cambridge and then after that I
came to New York and I thought I would
do that for one year because I wanted to
have the New York experience and I never
used my return ticket Here I am you're
still having the New York experience I'm
still having the New York difference
exactly so to you as I understand it
grew up among Holocaust survivors and
and I would love to hear you elaborate
on that experience and what it was like
what you what you learned from it and
and then we can talk about I'd like to
talk about Jerusalem but look I am am
very interested as many people are in
the history of the Holocaust but even
more than that the personal lived
experience the lived experience and
there's a book called if this is a man
and there's another book called the
truce both are written by primo levy
which was recommended to me by the
illusionist David Blaine who actually
has primo Levy's inmate number or
prisoner number tattooed on his forearm
and it was one of the most impactful
books I would say I've read in the last
10 years but I have no direct experience
with Holocaust survivors what was that
what was that like and what did you
learn hmm so interesting that we're
starting from there so I think that if
this was a man bike simulator is one of
the most powerful books one ought to
read I think it's a it's a unique a
unique Testament so it's very simple
there were 60,000 Jews in Belgium before
the war the vast majority of them were
decimated throughout the war
in camps and so after the war a group of
Eastern European Jews basically came to
Belgium for all kinds of means that's
kind of where they arrived and my
parents who were both the sole survivors
of their entire family which means 200
people lost I guess on every side they
were both the youngest in their families
my mother was in the camps from 18 to 22
and my father from 25 to 30 one actually
because the war started very early for
them so they they they came you know
with nothing to buy to be there for
three months they were illegal refugees
no they were legal refugees for three
months were meant to continue from there
to other countries where they had been
given refugee status but they didn't
they chose not to leave and so they
stayed for another five years as as a
legal refugees in Belgium which is very
settling for me right now with what's
going on in our country here and I'm
born later so when I am born in 15 years
they already found a way to legalize
themselves to become a Belgian citizens
and and I grew up in a different
environment but I am growing up in a
community of 20,000 Jews that are all
Holocaust survivors that's basically all
we knew in the Jewish community of
course there was the larger version
community around and you know you saw
numbers you asked why don't we have
grandparents you asked what are these
numbers you you you know it was kind of
Indian it came with mothers milk is the
best way I could say it it was so
ever-present we spoke Yiddish German
Polish French and Flemish in my home
depending on the subject matter we
changed and depending on who was
speaking to whom the language change but
they were they were five vibrant
interchangeable languages going on the
whole time and if you can imagine that
the language is a door to a world then
you can imagine how many words were
coexisting at the same time that had
thing to do with each other actually I
grew up above the store in a because
most of the Jews of Antwerp were
actually our in the diamond business my
family was among the 2% that were not
and so they had clothing stores and I
grew up in the neighborhood where they
were - Jewish families so it's like the
belly store with the foreigner in the
neighborhood you know and you know who
they are the two foreigners and they
have an accent and they look different
and the whole thing and I lived above
the store and in this very popular
neighborhood lower middle class
neighborhood and where we spoke actually
not even just Flemish but we spoke
dialect Flemish from the street like
from the hood the equivalent of the
hoods basically and I would straddle
back and forth you know one of the ways
I can describe it is my father when he
turned 50 had two birthday parties one
birthday party was for his Jewish
survivor friends that took place in
addition in Polish and with a lot of
vodka one birthday party was with his
Flemish friends and that was in dialect
and with a lot of beer and by the code
by the drinks you knew exactly which
world you were traveling in and how how
you had to behave and how much you could
show that side of you versus the other
side of you and you know and there was a
sense I think maybe more than anything
when you grow up in that kind of a
community you you grow up with the
notion of impermanence that what is
today could disappear any moment I think
that's probably one of the strongest
experiences you don't ever think that
there is a notion of you know what is
now will be there tomorrow you'd never
know and so you learn to adapt to that
notion of impermanence of insecurity if
you want and in my parents were where
both Yvonne you know they loved life
they didn't survive for nothing they
were going to enjoy at best and
as I have often said they understood the
erotic as an antidote to death I think
they knew how to keep themselves alive
and and then enjoy they were not
everybody was like that you had very
different kind of moods they were
storytellers so people would come from
everywhere and they would tell about
their life and their experiences and
they were good storytellers which means
that they knew how to screen out and to
could make you laugh and they didn't
make you completely tense when you would
listen and everybody wanted to know
their stories they were amazing amazing
amazing stories of survival of of
subversion of you know my dad was
illiterate he spoke five languages but
he was basically literate and he was a
grand grand human being you know who had
done a lot and had saved quantities of
people because yeah we'd say maybe the
best the strongest value in that kin
in that community another strong is been
one of the very strong values one was
definitely decency you know how you
behave towards your fellow other people
and the other one was how would you say
that in English to manage street smart
to be street smart you know to know to
survive basically to find your way out
of situations and to be able to to
survive survival was the central
organizing experience of all these
people and then the second experience
was revival and I have so many different
directions that I would love to take
this so I'll try to do it one is time
dialect Flemish from the hood could you
give us any example of what Street
Flemish sounds like or their manikin I
think that is it cos in advance with
Bella it's also what did you just say
yes dude do you want me to say this in
an twin Antrim dialect how would you say
how are you in like what's up in
Provence so their wartime who fought it
oh boy
yes I'll save my embarrassing rehearsal
for when we meet in person
like in Adela moment in time claps
clapping and I Kanaka Kalamazoo v
telomere mechanics are talking entangles
accusation ah I think you might have
just insulted my ancestors but I'm not
sure what just happened I said I said I
could say all of this in Antwerp dialect
but in order to be sure we all
understand it I'm going to tell my
stories in English that is a fantastic
idea so thank you for that I love
languages so I just wanted to hear
something that I had never heard before
you mentioned that your parents were
sole survivors in their families if I
heard you correctly when you look at
your parents and I don't know if it was
simply because of their age or or other
factors but when you look at your
parents so that that would be the
primary focus but at end at other sole
survivors what did they credit the
survival to oh that is a great question
I did go to I did get to ask them these
questions so my mother she first spent
one year in the woods at 18 running from
farm to farm hiding in the woods of
Poland and then she was so terrified
that she actually surrendered by herself
to a camp to a labor camp to a man's
camp because she thought if I am in a
camp at least then probably will put me
in the kitchens or in the laundry and I
could at least wake up every morning in
the same place my mother ended up going
to nine different labor camps now labor
camps were generally next door to the
concentration camps and as long as you
could work you were in the labor camp
and if you were not selected that
morning for transport then you could
continue work but the distinction is
often a very narrow distinction and my
father was in 14 camps and my mother
definitely so the rest of their families
was either gassed in kubinka or in
Auschwitz basically his family now it's
her family in Treblinka and my mother
would say it was a combination of
premonitions dreams she was very very
superstitious and she really believed
her
dreams that we tell her tomorrow don't
go there tomorrow be a little bit late
there tomorrow make sure to have an
extra layer of loose paper on your feet
because it's going to be really really
cold she had all these premonitions
dreams of her father talking to her and
things like that and she will always say
chance came first my father too I think
ultimately both of them said chance came
first and then there was what you did
with the chance that was given to you
right and so there is always a mixture
between choice and coincidence choice
and chance and my mother said she always
made sure that she was clean that she
was groomed that she was mending her
socks that she maintained her humanity
that she didn't allow herself to become
dehumanized and degraded the way that
she was being treated by the Nazis and
my father my father when we went to
visit our Suites actually ended up
telling me a story of a dutch convoy
that arrived of women and he somehow
picked a woman out of the crowd and he
decided that he would help this woman
and basically the next day they were
shaven and so he couldn't even recognize
her so he asked a capo who is the other
woman that he had meant noticed the day
before and they began some
correspondence which I have no idea how
he wrote because he couldn't write and I
never bothered asking him who wrote for
you but he fell in love with his woman
and he just decided that there were
certain things that that the Germans can
take away from him and that had to do
with feelings and we'd love in the most
dire of circumstances and then he
basically developed this black market in
one of the camps where he was with his
best friend where they were for almost a
year and a half where he ended up
feeding 60 young men who would otherwise
not have had enough to eat and therefore
to work and therefore to survive and he
ended up feeding the Nazis too so when
he got caught with those letters one of
the Germans basically sent him back to
factories and said you're not staying in
here you can factories mentioned you
have one week to live basically and but
he had been feeding the German guys so
well that the guy said I eat better when
you work in the kitchens and he'd put
him back in the kitchen and so he always
said it was a combination of chance and
ingenuity street-smart what he would
call and and doing for others doing for
others gave you a purpose to stay alive
and to wake up in the morning and if you
look at then the survivors whether by
chance first like you mentioned choice
some combination of those factors and
others you mentioned survival and
revival when you look at the survivors
who ended up being able to revive
themselves and to and who did not
so the third reason my mother always
said is that she always thought that
they wanted her to stay alive because if
the others were not going to make it
they needed to be at least someone from
the family and she always thought that
she would somehow be reunited with
somebody so she maintained this very
deep connection inside of her that they
were waiting for her somewhere then they
realized that there was nobody so I you
know it's an interesting question that I
organized in my mind like this and I
organized it when I was actually writing
mating my first book mating in captivity
I at the time I had a conversation with
my husband and who was working with
survivors of torture and political
violence and I would ask him when do you
know that people come back like what did
it mean to come back right come back
from from different war zones to come
back from having been kidnapped to come
back from solitary confinement and and
and and what does it mean to come back
to life and then as we were talking you
know it became very clear that when you
reconnect with life not just when you
are surviving but when
and living it means that you once again
able to take risks able to brought out
to go into the world able to play
because you cannot play if you are in a
constant state of vigilance and
guardedness and able to trust and then I
thought to myself oh my god this is so
much what I saw in ant world you know I
remember since my entire classroom were
children of similar family that they
were always two groups of families in my
community and then I decided that I
would call this there was one group that
did not die and one group that came back
to life and did not die you could feel
it when you went to their houses you
know they often had plastics over the
couches and the the curtains were pulled
down there was more bit it was just you
know you you're not dead but you're not
celebrating your life you certainly are
not enjoying because if you enjoyed and
you are not being careful and you have
guilt you often have survival guilt why
am I here and none of the others made it
and you are weighted down and the world
is a dangerous place and you are not to
trust anyone outside the family and all
of that and then I thought there is
those who came back to life and that's
that's what led me actually to really
want to explore what is a roti season
what is this antidote that how in the
face of adversity do you continue to
imagine yourself you know rising above
it connected to joy to love to pleasure
to beauty to adventure to mystery to all
of that and and that those people you
know it was very interesting you had
people who came together because they
were the survivors of this camp and the
survivors of that camp and then you had
people who came together for this kind
of holiday or that kind of celebration
and they never discussed their
experiences it was all implicit but they
were together and they they were
charging ahead of life you know the
first thing they did when they would
come out of the camps by the way to have
a child because I'm alone you're alone I
have nothing you have nothing let's get
married and let's have children because
if we have a child and we
that we are still human we are able to
procreate and we create legacy and they
didn't kill everything off and so my
parents you know they planted trees in
all kinds of places in the world they
put claxon in the memory of all the
other people of their families my mother
at one point we see $10,000 in the years
in 99
she received $10,000 from one of the
factories of slave labor and their neck
decades later and she took the $10,000
and she went and planted an entire
forest that had just burned and she
replanted a forest because it was like
firming life you know and affirming an
aliveness with a sense of defiance you
didn't you know it didn't all die inside
and I think it's that energy that life
force that really I think defines and
this is true for my community but I
would apply this to any large scale
trauma that communities experience I
don't think it's unique I agree and I
don't know why I want to ask you this
question right now but you mentioned
trust as one of the elements one of the
ingredients in the group that was
revived that was living and not just
having avoided death do you think that
and these are not mutually exclusive but
distrust come first and then
vulnerability or does vulnerability come
first and that's how you develop trust
that depends on your theory of trust
this is the big debate on trust
theorists you know Rachel Botsman will
tell you that Trust is an active
engagement with the unknown and and
therefore you you know so that's one
direction and the other direction is
that it is the actual experience of
vulnerability that allows you to then
trust and it goes in both directions it
really I don't think there is a
definitive answer for that and maybe
it's not an either/or but it's a both
hands and right you know for some people
it's like do you need to know in order
to taste or do you want to taste first
and then be told when it was definitely
depends on what type of cuisine or what
type of chef but I understand we really
need to be able to trust in order to get
off from your lap and to run into the
world and to be come in to explore and
discover and play and be gone in their
own space and at the same time it is the
act of doing all of that and coming back
to base and sitting themselves rubbing
themselves back on your lap that
reinforces the trust I actually tend to
think more in dialectic terms in both
hands rather than either/or but I think
it's a fantastic question the question
of trust you know do does the act of
trusting release the option the
possibilities to experience the
vulnerability or is the vulnerability of
the unknown that that you actually
engage with ultimately what builds the
trust right this is something I've been
thinking quite a lot about but I want to
also ask you about impermanence and I've
tried to focus much more in a sense on
things that are impermanent in my life
in the last year year and a half and in
part that was a result of a conversation
I had on this podcast with BJ Miller who
is a a hospice care physician so he's
helped more than a thousand people to
die great guy he lives here dead
together yeah yes so fantastic guy I was
actually so I went to Princeton
undergraduate and he was one of the
warning stories because he lost three of
his limbs in an electrocution accident a
few years before I went to school there
I asked him what the most what purchase
of less than a hundred dollars had most
positively impacted his life in the last
six months a year whatever he could pull
from memory and he and he mentioned a
bottle of wine and it wasn't an
expensive bottle of wine and the reason
he mentioned it was and I'm going to
paraphrase here but he said it was the
fact that it went away and the how that
encouraged you to enjoy something that
you knew wasn't permanent and so I've
thought about that a lot since and how
to not
see ur things being impermanent but
really use it as a source of of leverage
to maximally enjoy those things while
you can and I'm curious how your parents
ability to savor impermanence impacted
you or your behaviors or your routines
or anything if it did I don't know oh I
would say in two ways
first of all I'm rather voracious in
dealing it's a you know if there's one
more experience I can have one more
thing I can discover one more place I
can travel to one more conversation that
could be interesting I am quite
voracious I not because in because I'm
insatiable but because I just because a
part of me always says who knows what
will be tomorrow right you know I don't
live with that there is always a
tomorrow I will I live with who knows if
there will be a tomorrow
and that's very simple and then the
other thing I would say that that maybe
something that's not always that so so
known about me but you know I I also
live in a bit of a what we call in my
jargon a counter phobic way which means
I act as if I'm fearless but I'm
actually petrified with dread ok please
Allah please elaborate counter phobic
act as if I'm fearless counter phobic
means like I act like nothing's like it
doesn't not nothing but like there's a
lot of things I do that could be very
scary sometimes to other people anyway
and I and I leave it as if I have no
fear you know even today I was I was
driving down on my bike and and I was
thinking like last week it was filled
with snow here why am I always just
pushing the edge and seeing if I can get
away with it and and you know the truth
is I got on my bike in the snow and and
I realized there was no way I was going
to be able to do this and I put the bike
back but I was thinking how many times I
do things thinking not
things going to happen and at the same
time as I do it I think at some point
something bad is going to happen it's
the bow it's that what that means like I
live I you would think that and I
wouldn't do it if I think something bad
can happen it would stop me but no I do
it and at the same time I think
something bad is going to happen every
day I think something bad is going to
happen
do you do you wish that we're different
or do you think that helps you in some
well god I wish it was different I mean
yes I'm sure it pushes me and stuff but
but there must be a way to live without
that constant fear like that I know it
prepares me very well for the for the
modern times we live in I can tolerate a
lot of uncertainty you know and the
political climate weary and all of that
but you know to be in Antwerp there was
another car that drove on the main drag
you know driving into people you know
it's like that's not a surprise to me
where I expected that's what I mean it's
like I live with that expectation it's
just a matter of when not a matter of if
but I think it creates a level of
anxiety that I don't wish on anybody no
I don't think it's a it's normal I
actually don't think I think it's normal
given the history I come from I don't
think it's a good way to live let's
let's talk about this antidote that you
mentioned earlier so the erotic is an
antidote to death but actually I'm going
to interrupt myself and before we get
there
how old were you when you went to
Jerusalem eighteen eighteen and why did
you go to Jerusalem was that your choice
someone else's suggestion why did that
happen
so before I went to Jerusalem I actually
came to the states and I hitchhiked
across the country for seven weeks in
1976 calculate sorceress ID you know but
in the Bicentennial and at a time you
could still hitchhike very freely and I
had one of the most formative
experiences of my life because I saw
America like I don't think I would ever
see it again since I had zero
reference I had no judgment and I just
was welcoming of anybody who was willing
to pick me up and take me in
I really saw the country in and out in
you isn't that I don't think I wish my
kids could have an experience like this
but I don't know that this is happening
these days and then I went to Jerusalem
because I didn't want to study in
Belgium I didn't like the university
system in Belgium why not why not
because we have a system where you have
to study a curriculum that is prepared
by the teacher and you have to
regurgitate it and studied rather by
heart and I thought it was a 19th
century system it really was not at all
you know a useful way of learning and I
had done that already for 12 years
before you know I studied Latin I
studied great five six hours a week I
mean I have the whole classic education
humanistic education and I told you
whose name was mysterious mystical
beautiful complex you know in in the
middle of these hot beds of all
religions and we were going to Israel a
lot with my family so that that was not
it's not like it was a place I didn't
know and I thought it was the one place
that I could leave to study abroad with
my parents blessing so it was very very
easy it's like for them that you know
you didn't come to study in America at
that time or and I had a choice between
I was I was very passionate about
theater and and my mother said if you
want to do theater you stay in Belgium
and if you want to travel then you have
to go to university I want you to have a
structure and I thought if it's
University Hebrew University is a great
university the city is magnificent and
at the time it was really a spectacular
place and it was much more open than it
is now and and I thought what an
adventure I mean I didn't need much
explanation at that time it made it
didn't make sense and it made perfect
sense did you have any if you look back
at your time in Belgium and Jerusalem
were there any particular mentors
who leap out at you if you had to give
give them credit for helping steer your
life in the direction that it's gone or
help you to make any very important
decisions is there anyone who really
jumps out of you besides your besides
your parents yeah yeah
so it's interesting you're asking me
today because I am going to Washington
tomorrow to a big psychotherapy
conference called the psychotherapy
symposium and I am doing an homage to my
mentor but the mentor from America who
is 95 and I have been asked to be one of
three people to be the person to thank
him so I'm in the midst of this
experience right now in order to say to
one of the most influential teachers of
my life I would say in Jerusalem we
could also talk about that 95 year old
mentor that's totally fine as well or
both both that yeah I mean it's an
interesting question I am the product of
mentorship this is this is true
throughout from Hebrew University to
Cambridge Massachusetts to studying with
salvador minuchin that's the name of
this mentor I have been mentored pretty
much too but even in my adolescent to my
theater teacher and dance teacher I
tried
mainly because my parents could always
help me with any of these things they
had zero reference to the world I lived
in I solved teachers I thought mentors I
thought people who could help me
integrate in belgian life who could help
me you know trust believe in myself as
well you know guide me my brother was
definitely one of them and we were you
know who was in every book I read was
recommended by him but I am totally the
product of mentorship and it's like I
sought them out then one after the other
I this meant that I'm going to be
commemorating tomorrow either life but
salvador minuchin who is one of the
fathers of the field of systemic family
therapy how do you spell Salvador's last
name me newton mi nu
see I CH I n got it the Newton Union I
mean you know you're anointed when you
have studied with him it's like it's
it's like studying with Freud a century
later and I knocked at his door I
arrived to New York I was here I knew I
have been here to be in New York I
knocked at his door and I said can I
come and observe he looked at me like
who are you and that's the story I'm
going to tell two more like at the time
you could still knock at somebody's door
and say I want to learn from you you
inspire me and then you let me stay
there 10 weeks and then after 10 weeks
she said that's it that's about as much
as one can learn from I'm observing that
you can go now and I said no no no no no
I have to you know please please let me
stay
that's Canada England I always said like
I enter through the window you know so I
actually want to start to interrupt but
I want to dig a little deeper on that
because I am constantly asked by well
I'm asked to mentor which usually means
unpaid consultant for life said I don't
often say yes to that but the question
of how should I approach mentors or how
should I seek people out like Salvador
and someone along the lines of your
story a little bit different but I
remember a professor who had a profound
impact on the edge Chou
who is at Princeton and was a very
eclectic character is it was similar in
his appeal to me as Richard Fineman
because they were so they're so diverse
in their interest so he was a
competitive figure skater had taken
several companies public was the first I
believe the first computer science
professor at Stanford because the person
was supposed to teach it didn't show up
and then the administration asked if
anyone would volunteer and he did I was
a congressman for a few terms and I
really wanted to be in this class but I
came back from overseas and I was late
to apply to this class which had become
very very popular called high technology
partnership and so I so I went to the
first class and I peeled him and I said
I'll sit on the floor I'll clean the
erasers I'll do whatever is necessary
can I just sit in on a few classes
so is it was somewhat similar approach
but when people ask you and I'm sure
they do how should I seek out mentors
how should I approach people I want to
learn from what what advice would you
give them and maybe any specifics from
what you've done in the past did you
just knock on door of his classroom or
was it his office his classroom I mean I
I I could I said I'm in New York and uh
and so-and-so suggested that I could
meet with you I would love to learn with
you I had nothing no credentials I had
no reason to be there
could I see no because I get my foot in
the door and I'd like you I would have
done exactly what you did I would have
said I'll do anything I'll bring you
coffee every morning Jen I just be here
because I just needed my foot in the
door and then I told you know then I can
start thinking and now what I and I
admire the people who do that with me I
have to say when they come and they fly
and they write and they say you I've
been reading you I've been you know and
then they show me not just I'd like you
all right all right I'd marry you but
also they say a few things that let me
know that they get what I'm talking
about
so I also feel deeply understood and
then I feel like oh man I was there I
was the 21 year old you know and I had
no papers I had no visa I mean I was I
came here with love and fresh water
really and that's what I mean street
smile it's like you know refugee go for
it knock at the doors and and if they
say no come back again if you have to
third time if you don't act crazy they
really understand that you are deeply
motivated and that and and if you do it
with somebody who did it do that if you
don't that crazy is a really important
bolded part of that sentence expiry have
to be really you know you you're not a
cuckoo you're not like just some loose
screw but you really show that you I see
you and I want you to reject me or I
want to learn from your trajectory after
ten weeks when you said you're out and I
said please please she said you
can be a fly on the wall and I said fine
how do you fly in the world you will I
will melt in the wall no no let me be as
invisible as can be and then one day
there was a couple that was their family
and it was actually a Holocaust survivor
family working with the with the
therapist behind a one-way mirror that's
how we were learning at a time and then
somehow suddenly he looks at me and he
says you there in the back don't you
know something about this and I said he
said what would you do I thought you
know and then I like spouted something
out and then he says that's an
interesting thought go tell them and he
literally sent me to the other side of
the station and and I thought oh ha no
longer invisible I exist and that was
the beginning then I worked with him for
the next four years that's amazing so
spies the word in Yiddish oh yes hutzpah
yes good healthy creative imaginative
food spa yeah need more more foot spa
I'm not saying it correctly unless what
is it perfectly less less mishegoss
right as you know I think that Mentors I
agree that sometimes it's kind of a
consultant dig for life but sometimes
it's just you must have had authors of
books or musicians those that you read
when you were young that kind of really
shaped you and it's a very strange thing
when suddenly you become a shaping force
in someone else's lives so some reason
you speak to them and I am always
curious why me like what is it that I
say because other people talk about some
of these things that touches you that
you would want to come here from faraway
countries just to meet with me and
another patient now go and have a cup of
coffee with these people or you know
that's why I have responded more than
once just by the way they write the
letter it's all in how they
that male to me that can't expect you
know there's no logic are there any key
ingredients that you can think of I'll
share from my side as well so one of the
things that and I mean we both get I'm
sure a lot more inbound than we could
possibly ever respond to but one of the
things that I would say certainly
there's a there's it can't be ten pages
long but that's obvious I would say that
very often people think that it is a
form of optimism that will be rewarded
if if they end with and I look forward
to your favorable response or how about
next Tuesday and I'm not personally
someone who generally responds to that
very well I'm more likely to respond if
they close with something like I
completely understand if I never hear
from you because you must have an
incredible amount of inbound requests
like this but if you've read this far
thank you at least for reading this far
and it's it's it lets me off the hook
counter-intuitively maybe that makes it
more likely that I'll respond because I
perceive they have some empathy or
ability to understand the situation that
I'm in so that would be one in
contributing ingredient for me and then
the other I remember I ended up hiring
someone years ago to work on help me
work on the 4-hour body in and some
other projects because he heard me
talking about things that I needed or
read about certain projects I was going
to be working on he said oh I just went
ahead and did ABCD and here's the work
you don't have to respond I just thought
this would be helpful and I was like
well okay that's very proactive what
about yourself
yes it's a combination I mean what you
just described I mean it's a combination
between boldness and humility right you
know the boldness is I'm going to do
this
I've been reading you have been
listening to you something in the way
you say it strikes it right for me but I
don't expect it I totally know what I'm
asking you and it would mean an enormous
amount I have no reason to do this but
if you were to do this
it could change my life it would mean so
much and it's it's not so much that I
can say no yes it's that they really
understand the vulnerability of the
request you feel that they they are
prepared for you to say no and they are
so if they were to hear yes it would
mean so much and I have been there I
remembered you know I've been that
person so it's a it's you can't write to
me as if you already know everything but
at the same time you have to be bold
enough to want to say what do I have to
lose what do I have to do and then this
is and then I have never written
something like this I and then I would
probably say one thing for me that makes
a difference is if they just say you
know I've always wanted to be a
therapist to work with sexuality and
couples know but if they see in the way
if they reflect back something about me
in which I recognize myself and it's a
mirror that I like to look in at then I
feel like they know what they really get
what I'm about and what I'm talking
they're not just projecting onto me you
know and then that helps then I feel
also really understood it's a variation
of what you're described in terms of the
empathy setting is similar it's a
different wording for something that's
not that's quite similar to what you
described that sounds similar so I
promise to get back to this and I know
people are going to want to dig into
this will continue to bounce all over
the place but you mentioned the the
erotic as an antidote to death
what is errata sysm and can you explain
what you mean by it being an antidote to
death yes yes animals have sex and we
have the erotic and the erotic is
sexuality that is transformed by our
human imagination
the erotic is the meaning that you
attribute to sexuality it's the poetics
of sex it's not nature instinct primary
force
it's everything that gives it a meaning
and in a context
it's everything that turns sex not into
an act but into a place you go not just
something you do but a place that you go
and that place that you go is a place
where you connect with vibrancy with
aliveness with renewal with lifeforce
with vitality with mystery and that's
why it becomes an antidote that that's
why people often talk about it in
spiritual terms in religious terms it
has a transcending quality to it it's
really the more mystical meaning of the
word erotic you know it was Zohar life
force it's really modernity that
narrowed the meaning of a eroticism to
something that is more blatantly sexual
rather than lifeforce but that life
force you know often expressed through
the sex takes on a whole other dimension
so for me to understand that I wasn't
just working on sexuality because I'm
not interested in what people do the act
the you know you can do sex and feel
nothing women have done sex and sell
dead for centuries
you know it's really that other side of
it and that you don't have to do much of
anything your own imagination you know
we are the only ones who can have sex
for hours you know blissful section and
a wonderful connection and orgasms and
all the legs and never touch anybody
just because we can imagine it and that
imagination is ability to transport
ourselves outside of this moment that we
are in into something completely
different that is the erotic alone and I
am very interested in that because
because I work with people who come and
complain about the loss of desire and
the loss of that energy and they want to
reconnect with that force and they don't
know why they lose it and they confuse
it with arousal and it has not much to
do with that and you know when people
complain about the listlessness of their
sex lives they sometimes make them want
more sex but they always want better and
that better but when you run and analyze
it with them it's about that life force
that vitality and vibrancy that Miss
three that imaginative play that
curiosity curiosity is an essential
ingredient of the erotic and that's what
they want to reconnect with and so then
that metaphor that I talked before about
not dead versus alive survival versus
revival that you know you can survive
and have sex and have children but you
may feel dead whereas you can can have
an expense in which you feel utterly
alive and you in your 80s and you do
whatever 80 people year old people do it
doesn't really matter because because
the force transcends the act and that's
for me the interest of working on a
rhotacism
by work with people who want to feel
alive if you say look at your group of
patients and you then look at a subset
who are what they would consider happily
married in the sense or happily in a
committed relationship
maybe committed is too low to determine
they're happily in relationship and they
don't want to leave that relationship
there are many incredible elements of
that yet they've they've hit that point
which many people have hit certainly
I've hit before I am very good I'll to
make this personal so I'm very good at
monogamy I can do it very very good at
it but after say a year a year and a
half I have to where I feel like I have
to suffocate a part of myself that were
subjugates my sex drive so that I don't
wander and that ends up affecting sex
with my primary partner with my partner
in this case so if you have if you're
talking to these people and they and
they hit a point where they feel sex
drive decrease or listlessness what do
you view as the ethical options that are
on the table to address that okay but
they're like four sub sub sub topics yes
no exactly there's there's there's
there's a lot a lot of that that was
probably a far too complex a question
but I suppose making it personal is
leading me to do that no no I know it's
you know so you know making in captivity
for me well
really a conversation on that very
question that you just asked right
people would come to me and they would
say we love each other very much
we have no sex or we love each other
very much where is the desire or you
know which was very different from the
traditional model that you would
normally learn in school which was of
course if there is no sex people mustn't
love each other because when one needs
automatically to the other and therefore
sexual problems are always the
consequence of relationship problems and
you should fix the relationship and the
sex will automatically follow that was
the premise and I decided to question
that premise because it didn't really
work like that in my office I saw people
who got along much better and it still
didn't change anything for the desire
and so I began to ask what is the
relationship between love and desire
yeah
so that's the first one is what what
does that mean this is desire fade to
the grave you know is the degradation of
desire inevitable and what does it mean
and how does one rekindle it and can one
we can delete and can you want what you
already have which is the fundamental
question of desire and then there is the
second part to what you're asking which
is the question of monogamy you know and
when you say I can do monogamy very well
for a year then you are defining
monogamy by one criteria only at least
in the way I've understood you where you
speak is that you're defining monogamy
as a sexual exclusivity sure in this
particular case that's that's what that
means but that's one definition of
monogamy because you know monogamy is a
term that has continuously evolved in
its meaning right I mean for most of
history monogamy was one person for life
at this point monogamy is one person at
a time that's right Rick and everybody
goes around saying I'm monogamous in all
my relationships well that doesn't mean
I had like an orgy in it every five
minutes there is one person I didn't
know I know I'm kidding but we have a
model of sequential analysis right now
plus we don't arrive we don't we don't
arrive monogamous to our relationships
we've had previous ones so I
this point where does monogamy exist in
reality but not in your history and not
in your fantasies so that's another
consideration and then there is you know
maybe if we stopped just looking at
monogamy from the exclusivity model
because the exclusivity model is an
economics model monogamy generally while
history has been an imposition on women
it has not necessarily been a
requirement for men in fact men
practically had a license not to be and
they have had all kinds of theories to
justify why they shouldn't have to be
because we needed to know about
paternity and about patrimony and
lineage so monogamy had nothing to do
with love
it had everything to do with an economic
system that word has transformed since
romanticism so much that at this point I
think that the conversation about
monogamy should probably be less a
conversation about sex and sexual
boundaries and sexual exclusivity and
more about the multiplicity of
relationship configurations in which
monogamy may be more emotionally
determined rather than just sexually
determined like gay couples have done
forever I think we need to loosen up the
term not totally trash it or not totally
bind it but certainly untie it you know
loosen it up and redefine it now
within that it's a choice monogamy it's
significant you choose to practice when
you keep it in the definition you want
and then the question is what do people
do with their thwarted desires with
their other attractions definitely they
have them they can acknowledge them they
can have a relationship in which they
negotiate with each other what to do
with these other desires they can
hopefully not always interpret them as
you're not enough which is the most
powerful reaction that people have today
to this to that term and the majority of
people have practiced proclaimed
monogamy and clandestine adultery I mean
that been the dominant model sure you
know the question is simply do people
want to have a [ __ ]
with themselves that is private and
secretive or do people want to
incorporate this as part of the
conversation of couple making at this
point we're not meant to have desire for
one person for life for 60 years that is
not how we were conceived by the way we
ever conceived of having 60 year
relationships with the same person
either for that matter so we are left
with a host of new questions about the
nature of erotic desire they are given
first of all that for until very
recently we didn't have sex in
relationships just because because of a
desire we had it for procreation and
generally for women it was a marriage of
Duty so sex that is rooted in freewill
for pleasure and connections just
because we want it and with you and
hopefully at the same time and so forth
is a very new model and we are all
grappling with it everybody is wondering
you know what do you do with the lots of
desire how important is sex anyway can
the relationship sustain without sex can
the relationship sustain with sex with
others while having a relationship what
are the boundaries I mean this is the
conversation of modern loves is one of
them anyway there's a few but this is
one of the dominant conversation of
modern love so I don't know if I've
answered you but I hope I've kind of
highlighted some of the flash points no
you have and I think we can I mean we've
we've got the time so we're going to
keep going I have so you mentioned and I
think this is a very important
observation that you know adultery used
to threaten economic stability now it
threatens moreso emotional stability
although in some senses certainly if
you're within the legal construct of
marriage there can be economic
ramifications certainly and I'm going to
bring it bring it home to San Francisco
for a second so I live in San Francisco
that's home base and I've tried
different relationship configurations in
the past I'm not married I don't have
kids and I've had some some wonderful
relationships I'd say for the last 10 to
15 years I've done a better job of
setting my own boundaries understanding
other people's boundaries making sure
that all those are very explicit so that
whatever agreement we have at the very
least that the agreement is is clear so
I've had some really good relationships
what I've seen in the last say let's
call it five years it certainly existed
for longer than that but whether it's
books like more than two or opening up
or or others there is a trend at least
in the Bay Area for people to try what
they would consider monogamous or
polyamorous relationships and I have
just in the cohort that I've observed
and there are a lot in the Bay Area the
always honest all the time radical
candor approach seems to implode with
pretty spectacular fireworks on a
regular basis so the question I want to
pose is is there such a thing as too
much honesty and how do you think about
that when you are advising how do you
think about it whether yourself or in
your own relationships or how do you
advise your clients when they're
grappling with this you know should we
because for instance I'll give you and
for you out there who are sensitive
earmuffs cover your ears but there are
people have here who I can have a high
tolerance for say what they would call
compersion
for people who are who don't know that
word that is thanks way it's been
explained to me getting gratification or
pleasure from someone else's pleasure so
if your partner's having sex with
someone else you derive a certain amount
of pleasure from that so I know couples
who have tried this because they've been
told it's a more highly evolved
approach and so they'll sit down to
dinner and the let's just say in a
heteronormative relationship the male
will say so what was it like having
so-and-so inside you yesterday and
they'll try to have that conversation
and everything blows apart at the axles
and it just doesn't work there's some
people for whom it works very well but
how much honesty is too much on see is
there such
thing is too much honesty are there
other parameters that you've seen work
for people yes yes
but you see I think that you want there
to different cultural systems here so
when it comes to the polyamorous model
in San Francisco it is you know it is a
bit of a growing movement in the hot
beds of startup cultures like like
Silicon Valley because it's people who
choose a lifestyle that has to do with
an entrepreneurial mindset that aspires
to greater freedom of choice to
authenticity and flexibility and and so
there's a kind of a marriage between the
community let live there and the appeal
of of a more polyamorous life but for me
the question of honesty is actually much
broader than it extends way beyond and I
think clearly in the United States and
America prides itself on being a
pragmatic culture and as a pragmatic
culture it likes unvarnished directness
and it has all kinds of expressions for
conflating honesty with factual truth
say it as it is don't beat around the
bush
get to the point I mean there are so
many expressions in this culture that
favor explicit statement versus more
opaque communication you know that that
conflate the concept of the moral cure
of honesty has to do with truth-telling
and transparency that's the definition
there are many cultures in which honesty
means something very different honesty
is not about you know laying it all out
there it's actually about living
thinking about what the consequences
will be for the other person to live
with the truth it's not a confessional
model it's not rooted in Protestantism
and so so honesty is not about I have to
tell you everything I feel or everything
I've done it's about what will it be
like for you want to live with the
consequences of knowing and so you don't
say certain things because you want to
say face
the other person or because you you you
just don't see the point of it because
there's almost something slightly almost
aggressive about it a little bit you
know it's like what am I supposed to do
with all of this now right now you feel
better you're unloaded what about me
chanting and I think it's very cultural
from for me suddenly coming from from
Europe we don't necessarily think that
that's saying everything and putting it
all out there and and through telling
and transparency are the only markers of
importance I think we we think that
sometimes keeping things to yourself is
just as important not not everything
must be said and here this notion else
that connects with that is also that
intimacy is about saying everything it's
kind of wholesale sharing you know and
if you don't say everything then you
must be keeping a secret because the
opposite of transparency is secrecy and
there is a complete loss of privacy and
this is true in the intimate realm of
relationships that it is true in many
other sectors of our society privacy is
at risk and so people respond either
with the with the other extremes yes I
do think that they can be too much
sharing it's not too much honesty but it
is too much sharing and the sharing is
problematic when you think that that's
the definition of honesty so this is a
really important without clear what I
just it was clear no what's clear and I
think the the honesty it is does honesty
or 100% sharing always equal caring for
the other person or fostering intimacy I
think is an interesting question and
yeah also is no the answer is no yeah
sometimes of course it is but it's not a
given it's not a dogma you know I think
that actually holding back I think
making space for the other person I
think dealing with your own feelings I
think this idea that because I love you
I should be able to tell you everything
and if you don't tell me everything you
know then maybe you're not close and
this telling as being Vicar as becoming
almost like a
bit of a I deserve to know what are you
thinking what are you feeling why don't
you want to tell me like no those are
invitations those are not right right no
they have a right to enter another
person you invited in and the for those
people listening who want to have a very
illuminating but entertaining read short
read on this type of question and
radical honesty there's a great article
I think it's called I think you're fat
by AJ Jacobs at Esquire who is hilarious
and a good friend so you should read
that but I want to bring up an anecdote
and get your advice on or how you would
hear how you would advise someone so I
remember having lunch with close friend
of mine not two years ago I would say
and he he had a friend approached him
who had cheated on his wife he had had
an affair and he was grappling with
whether to tell his wife or not and my
friend my friend's advice was he said no
that is your burden to carry and you
carry that with you it's not fair to
inflict that on her because you want to
make yourself feel better after a very
very long conversation that was his
conclusion and so I'm curious to know in
a say patient setting if you have
someone male or female because certainly
women cheat and I've been cheated on
before I mean it happens certainly when
someone is grappling with whether to
tell their partner or not how do you
walk them through that decision what is
it that you want to tell your partner do
you want what is it that you wanted to
you want to tell that you fell in love
with someone else you want to tell that
you realized in having a fling with
someone else how much you loved her or
him you realized that you have been
lying to yourself all these years you
realize that it's time to get back into
gear because you've become lazy and
complacent you realize that you have
been keeping all kinds of sexual secrets
that have nothing to do with
non-monogamy but more with your history
what is it you want to tell you part
you want to tell that you you know
that's the first thing and and do you
want to tell something about what
happened to you in the meeting with the
other persons do you want to tell what
that meeting with the other person made
you think about your life do you want
you know we're not just talking about a
series of facts we're talking about the
meaning and the motives of the
transgression so that's the first thing
I ask what is the meanings and the
motives why did you do this how did this
happen to you where you're looking for
it did you choose it
did you just stumble into it did you
resist it did you not resist it did you
hope it would not you know are you
living with conflict I what is the guilt
that you're feeling what is the gift is
the gift that you realize that you don't
have desire for your partner it's begins
that you realize that your partner must
have been really terribly frustrated
because you've been a terrible lover to
your partner what is it
and so after before I ever wouldn't I
don't have to tell people do or don't
tell or don't tell I have I helped
people figure out what it is that they
would tell why would they want to tell
it and what do they think will happen to
the other person when they tell it to
them I think the notion that sometimes
not to tell is kinder than to tell the
way that your friend did is also one of
the many options it's not the only one
but it is definitely in the repertoire
that sometimes you tell to for your own
conscience and then the other person can
churn the whole night you know so there
is the positives and you know the the
liabilities and the positives of telling
and then there is the liabilities and
the positive of not telling what do you
think your partner would want to know
that's the other thing and when you want
to tell do you ask yourselves do you
think your partner would want to know
are you speaking because of your
thoughts today about the other person or
are you thinking of speaking because of
how you feel about yourself you know
there's a full spectrum of dishonesty
right there simple omissions there's
partial truths there's white lies is
blatant office creations and there's
mental hijacking I mean you know the
secrecy can be a cruel and secrecy can
be benevolent
you know and sometimes you lie to
protect yourself and sometimes you lie
in order to protect your partner and
then there is the ironic role reversal
in which sometimes you realize that
you've been lying to yourself and it was
you that you were deceiving and it's all
of that that you want to unpack all
those twists and tangles of lines before
you send people out because you can
never take anything back right you know
and the next thing that's going to
happen you're going to say I slept with
someone and then they want to know how
was it and then they want to know did
you fall in love with that person and
then they want to know maybe they don't
want to know so slow down mm-hmm
sit with this ponder it figure out what
this was about for you if it really
meant nothing what does that mean when
you say it meant nothing you mean to say
there's not supposed to threaten the
future of your relationship this is not
a person with whom you want to live but
even something that is meant to mean
nothing has psychological valence you
know people there's a lot of effort goes
into making something not mean anything
paradoxically for sure so you know sit
with that and I will sit with you for
whatever time it takes till we figure
this out and then maybe we'll write a
letter you're not just going to go there
and sit you can write a letter and
you're first going to hand write that
letter and you're going to get your
first version out which you probably
won't send in which you just cleanse you
so you do your own conscience cleaning
and the next letter will be the one in
which you're left thinking about you and
more thinking about your partner and
your relationship that's the steps now
that's that's very smart
the next question I want to ask which is
actually from the audience do you think
it's possible for a partner in a non
monogamous marriage could be
relationship to get over the fear of
being left by opening that door I think
this is very very this is a very common
question because maybe one person is
more enthusiastic or feels the need for
some form of non-monogamy meaning sexual
monogamy than the other or they're both
open to it but they haven't
experimented or experienced this for an
extended period of time or maybe they
have and they've been burned it do you
think it's possible for someone to get
over that fear of being left by opening
that door and what are some of these
strategies or coping mechanisms if so
but what if I told you that the person
who experiences that fear more openly
and is able to say for me this triggers
the fear of losing you all together is
actually experiencing a lesser fear than
the one who is wanting to have other
partners could you say that again please
yes see couples have a setup right in a
setup
every couple has a setup maybe it's an
organization right in every couple you
will often find one person who is more
in touch with the fear of losing the
other and one person who is more in
touch with the fear of losing themselves
one person more in touch with the fear
of abandonment and one person more in
touch with the fear of suffocation and
that tells you which is the one that is
more interested sometimes in
experiencing open boundaries and
non-monogamy or non exclusiveness anyway
but the person who wants the open
relationship presents as the one who
doesn't have the fear of abandonment
I see yourself but that doesn't mean
that their strategy isn't in fact one
that is meant to address an even bigger
fear of abandonment that the other it's
just that in this relationship the other
one is the one who gets to fill the
quota okay - yes sure okay the
understand couples have complementary
systems so I don't at face value we
believe that the one who said I'm afraid
to lose you is the only one with that
fear I believe we all have it but I
believe that the one who expresses it in
the couple isn't always the one for whom
it is actually the most intense sure
that no I agree with that its secrets of
a lot of relationships no I
I agree you understand the person who
gets to voice it it's actually sometimes
only voicing a fear that the other one
doesn't even voice oh no I agree I agree
okay well that said I think it really
depends it depends I would not have a
set answer for this there are plenty of
people who had first felt very scared
and then have learned to trust
differently and have learned to
understand that their partner really
comes back to them and in fact the more
they feel free the more they want to
come back to them and they really have
learned to trust that and then there are
others for whom it's excruciating it
just feels either a replay from
childhood either a sense that they are
not enough because they have really the
notion that you would need more than me
and that I can't fill all your needs
it's very very painful to them and they
bought into that that idea and with very
powerfully sometimes there is the sense
that you know you allow yourself
something that I don't why can't you
stop yourself there are other things
that I don't get and I don't go and get
them elsewhere
compromise should be a part of what both
of us do in the name of our relationship
I've seen it go both ways I've seen
people for whom it really became a way
to live that they never knew existed
and I've seen people for whom this is
just not the way they want to live they
don't want that fear they don't want to
remember every time their parents for
now that they didn't know if they were
coming back
they don't want that notion of what if
you will fall in love somewhere else
which of course in and of itself would
happen no matter what that threat is
always there that reality is part of any
couple but somehow I don't want to have
to know it with such vividness or
because I feel that there is something
lacking in me or I feel my own
insecurities and therefore every time
you go my insecurities get awakened it's
a complex system I would just say that
it generally works better when both
people are from the same tribe
when both people have that same
curiosity when both people experience
the the fluidity as something that is
additive and not something that's an
actually tick then it becomes an
enhancing experience rather than a
dreadful experience each time it so it's
very complicated when one person says to
the other I really want this and the
other one says this is hell for me I
can't live with this it's it's and and
there's very little flexibility
sometimes in that system because both
people feel it very intensely and more
than one relationship has had to end on
that basis so what I'd like to ask
following up on that because I think
this question is and I'm going to stop
hedging all my comments obviously
everybody listening this there are
million different ways to organize
relationship and a million different
sort of combinatorial approaches to it
right whether it's homosexual
heterosexual you know sexual I have no
idea you're right there are a million
different ways to go about it so I'm
just going to assume for the sake of
simplicity that a lot of people are in a
no sexual relationships this question is
very common I think from women who are
so the eight you have a male in a in a
relationship who wants more sexual
variety and the woman in many cases not
all cases is is it least around San
Francisco potentially open to that but
doesn't have the same sexual drive
necessarily as the male so the male is
going to exercise that option more than
she will and that leads to or
contributes to perhaps fostering some
degree of insecurity you know if he's
going to be seeing X number of other
people and I am not seeing Y number
equivalent of people then the likelihood
of him disappearing is is higher and the
MER I was told once by someone they said
well no one can take the
you're meant to be with now the way that
the content context in which that was
provided was to underscore the fact that
like you said whether you're you're
married not married in a relationship
have an explicit agreement or not the
potential in the risk for digression or
meeting someone else is always there but
I guess the the fuel on the fire here is
that when you explicitly give someone
the option the fear is that it's more
likely to happen and that's just more of
an observation the the I wanted to
mention two things that I've been very
curious about recently that's that seem
at least in the group that I've observed
to work pretty well even though I think
they are at least one of them is viewed
as pretty unfashionable and so I wanted
to get your take on it so the first one
is an arrangement and this I've only
heard once but I thought it was very
clever actually no not once twice was an
older gentleman he's in his sixties and
married for I want to say 20 plus years
has a number of kids I was asking him
about his marriage and he said well we
have an open relationship okay when
we're having some wine tell me more so
we continue talking he said the way I
asked him how do you prevent it from
causing problems and he said well every
relationship has problems so it's not
like one is immune and one is not but
his wife gives him a report card every
quarter so every three months he gets a
report card it was one to ten scale in
four categories lover husband provider
father and he's allowed to have a low
score in any one of those as long as his
average is high enough so they agreed on
what his average had to be so he might
say the overseas for a period of time on
business trips and he might also sleep
with other women so he's going to get a
low lover score a high provider score
and then the other two are sort of up
for up for debate but I found that very
I found that appealing maybe just
because I like measuring things as a way
of course correcting and keeping things
in check the second which which I
particularly like your thoughts on all
we can go anywhere with this is that
looking at maybe a contrast to the tell
me everything I'll tell you everything
breed of polyamorous relationships where
radical honesty is an underlying tenet
I've run into more than a few people who
effectively have a Don't Ask Don't Tell
policy and I it pains not to pain me to
say it but I suspect I'll get a decent
amount of backlash from my audience it
seems to work pretty well in the sense
that more than a few couples have said
look that whole polyamorous tell
everything and I know those are not
mutually dependent is not for us but as
long as you're safe as long as you don't
embarrass me then you can do what you
want and the policy is Don't Ask Don't
Tell I that seems very old-fashioned I
mean maybe the fact that it's a two-way
street makes it less old-fashioned but
what are your what are your thoughts on
that because it seems to me just
intuitively to be and maybe it's a
highly dependent the person but to be
less prone to kind of supernova
destruction versus the radical honesty
peace for most people do you have any
thoughts that's a mouthful I know but
I'm thinking about a lot of this stuff
for a long time so I think that I would
start and I would say that trust loyalty
and attachment
come in many forms and when you describe
this example and you like it because of
its measurements I would say I like it
because of its creativity because
there's thoughtfulness because there is
a shared complicity because it seems to
have worked because there's imaginative
'no sand resourcefulness in it and
because I think that couples often lack
a lot of that every other system gets
innovators and gets new ideas and put
into it all the time and it is
extraordinary how much relationships
enter into a certain mode and then stay
in it for decades right
so anything where I see couples coming
up with their own imaginative solutions
to various situations and then be
flexible about it and review it and
change it to me is great that's it and I
think that unfortunately coupledom does
not benefit from the same innovative
spirit that every other company in
entrepreneurial has space these days
gets to benefit there isn't one model
fits all and a certain couple may have
lived for a while in a monogamous
arrangement and exclusive arrangements
but then decided at some point because
of all kinds of issues having to do with
age with illness with with with success
would you name it with children living
with with a new awakening with lots of
weight you name it you name it there's
lots of triggers that make so many
people want to change their relational
arrangement and I think that if people
are going to stay together a long time
they need that ability to review their
relational arrangements and to negotiate
it and then to try something and then to
see if it works into tree I mean I can't
enough emphasize my desire for
flexibility to become part also of
coupledom so that it doesn't just be it
enters a groove it goes until it can't
and then it just kind of ends there well
it needs to be something a little bit
more
Riaan reaching there so the first thing
I think for some people Don't Ask Don't
Tell
works extremely well it gives them
enough privacy it makes them both know
that there is still the primary loyalty
and commitment there is an implicit
sense of knowing where one can go how
far one can go
etcetera etcetera and they need to be
ample continuous investment and
reassurance and building into the
relationship itself the point is not
that you should have you know the
leftovers at home and everything else
that is meaningful and exciting and and
and and interesting and engaging
elsewhere by definition you still want
to be able to put some you know loves in
your own fire for other people
transparency and radical honesty has
become an ideology
the problem is ideologies generally are
rigid well you know they don't lend
themselves to being adaptive and fluid
to to what's in front of you it becomes
a matter of principle rather than a
matter of what makes sense I still I may
be a little bit you know of the school
student make sense just does it work I
don't care if it's true or if it's right
does it work is it decent is it caring
it is warm you know it has it been
adapted it does it fit both people those
are the criterias you go back and forth
like a lightest Copic not just like two
ideas you know for many people the
notion of radical honesty transparency
truth-telling authenticity those have
become the values of the economy of
today and so is it in the economy of the
home we want experience you know we want
purposeful transformative you know
experiences we want them at home we want
them at work everywhere for other people
home is a different thing and in home it
meant to satisfy other needs etc etc and
there is a segmentation that is accepted
we have these kind of things we share
other things with other people and to me
it's really a matter of does it fit this
particular couple does it work for them
or is there one person who is quietly
hurting over a long time and kind of
giving in but there's a power dynamic
because the word we haven't used is that
in all these negotiation there is an
element of power you know there is power
when you bring in other people there is
power when you feel that the other
person can leave you there is power when
you have faced with the Verte of a
person who is constraining you there is
a dynamic of power in all of these
issues and the question is is there an
equity in the decision-making do broad
people feel that they have equal power
in their ability to to say what works
for them in this instance that you
describe what's beautiful is you feel
like you know whatever he does she gets
to evaluate him
and so the evaluation is power it's a
story worth you know in the good sense
of the word I use the word power and and
so they are calibrating power you know
you get to do things but I don't want to
have to suffer because of it I want to
know that I still get to primary goods I
want to know that I come first you know
and so you're now you want to go play go
play but don't play on my behalf and
don't play on my account I don't want a
devaluation of our assets because you
are incurring other revenues somewhere
else you know and they play with this
and so for this couple to me you know
I'm playing by I'm putting my script on
to it but I when I listen to the
description I'm looking at what is the
power distribution because the power is
the sovereignty the power is the is the
dignity of this otherwise you know all
these things become not power but power
maneuvers and that's a whole other thing
and that has nothing to do with just sex
alone you know this should take place
you know all every relationship is a
power dynamic I think that that has to
be laid out first inside of that we can
come up with so many different
arrangements that people will live for a
while and then switch that I I want to
just say that when I would say that to
the to the to the polyamory people as
well I mean it's like you know there is
a beautiful proliferation of
non-monogamy thinking that is taking
place okay and they're very different
from the feel of pioneers of the 60s and
the 70s and and but then of course you
know many of those people are the
children of the divorce and the
disillusioned and they're not rebelling
against commitment per se but they're
looking for me more realistic ways to
make their vows last and they've
concluded that that includes other
lovers and and I think that the form
takes you know can vary enormously you
can have occasional hall passes you can
have swingers who play with others you
can have established threesomes
foursomes complex polyamorous networks
all of these things have one purpose to
reconfigure love and family life which
we have done from time immemorial right
now it's in
your comment on power reminded me is it
gives Oscar Wilde said everything in the
world is about sex except sex sex is
about our champion so we spent so much
time with people grappling with these
issues what was the research process for
your new book and you that is I mean
really and fresh on the mind I would
think at this point for you what was the
drive behind why do another book and
what was the research process like huh
so you know mating in captivity looked
at the dilemmas of desire inside the
relationships and the state of affairs
which is my new book looks at what
happens when desire goes looking
elsewhere and I had gone to 20 countries
on book tour for mating and in many
places the only chapter people wanted to
talk about was the shadow of the third
the chapter on monogamy which was only
one chapter in that whole book and I
thought there's no way that I can do a
thorough study of desire without looking
at desire that goes wondering you know
what is warming desire like what is the
power of transgression why the forbidden
so erotic and what is this thing called
adultery which has been historically
condemned and universally practiced you
know and 50 like and and so I took me a
while this is ten years since I wrote
mating in captivity and not I take a
long time to think and I only write if I
feel I have something to say and
something to say means that I want to
change the conversation on the subject
and I want to just add one or two
thoughts I want to really frame the
conversation I want to take something
and and make a cultural shift around it
so for the past six years about I began
to travel the globe and have
conversations about the subject of
infidelity transgression twists love
affairs
[ __ ] buddies betrayal drama lying
deception cheating gas lighting from
both sides okay what is that what is gas
lighting I've heard this expression
point I don't know what it is if when I
say I know you are seeing somebody else
I know I know it I feel it or I've even
and you say no you're crazy this is
because of what your father did to you
you don't have annoyed and you'd
literally destroy the coherence of my
reality got it okay it's when you're
accused of something you turn it around
and then to the fracture but you also
literally begin to make me feel like I
have no longer a grasp on reality I say
god it's a real mental torture you know
it's not that you're denying is that
you're also saying is what's wrong with
me that I'm thinking this and then you
basically make me doubt myself and you
make me doubt that I actually that when
I think the tea is hot it's actually hot
you know I no longer know to trust the
word that I live in my perceptions my
thoughts my feelings and that becomes an
internal breakdown it drives people
crazy it's really cool actually so very
common but it's a cruel thing to do and
I saw you know I'm 34 years a couples
therapist I have a fascination for
couples
I work in seven languages I can take
them from all over the world and and I
began to only see couples who have been
affected by infidelity in one variation
or another I also did a TED talk in
Passau which has you know seven and a
half million people in a year or two and
I thought okay I've got 1,500 letters I
thought my god I'm walking confessional
the world is pouring their secrets onto
me on this subject anyway and let me try
to think it through let me really delve
into this and look at it from a systemic
point of view meaning if I ask an
audience you know have you have you had
any experience with affairs or
infidelity you know nobody's going to
lift their hand nobody is going to say I
cheated or I've been cheated on so
easily but if I ask
same audience have you been affected by
infidelity in your life I probably get
90% of the singers up it's an amazing
thing as the child or as the friend of
as the boss of as the lover as the other
woman as the partner as the person who
went out you name it and now it becomes
really a collective experience so I
wanted to look at it from all angles and
I see couples to three hours at a time
and I delve into the labyrinth of
passion all of it you know from both
from all sides and then I collected all
the data I wrote I transcribed hundreds
of hours of sessions I transcribed all
the letters and I began to gather and
then decide what are the main
assumptions at this point about this
subject how does our culture think about
this because no matter
by the way infidelity happens in
polyamorous couples too you know the
fact that you get an open license
doesn't prevent people from climbing the
fence
something about transgression is deeply
human and you've also observed the
definition of cheating continues to
expand right where you have sexting
texting dating apps watching porn I mean
the the wall is getting the inside of
the walls getting a yes narrower and
narrower in some respects also
absolutely the definition is elastic
it's unbelievable what people today how
many more ways that we we define
something as being outside of the of the
boundaries and we consider them in
Fidelity's and you know it is one of the
experiences that encompasses the entire
human drama everything jealousy hurt
betrayal
pain lust love passion all of it it's
like every opera there's a reason no and
and it is a one of the most complex
human experiences to really delve into
but it is it is like endlessly
fascinating and so I wanted to rethink
infidelity
what does it mean today why does it
happen in any kind of relationship what
does it mean to know that that your
partner never really belongs to you
they're only on loan and with an option
to renew or not so I related to that I
get asked about marriage and kids a lot
even though I feel very unqualified the
comment on either but what is the
argument for marriage these days because
I have trouble coming up with one the
argument that comes to mind because the
legal construct the financial
consequences the difficulty in the sort
of unraveling if you want to change
direction or a new chapter means a new
partner whatever it might be there there
are a lot of consequences now the
argument the only argument that I come
up with for it is related to loss
aversion where maybe if you really want
to make a strong committed effort to
maintain a relationship for a long
period of time that if you have
something to lose if you don't enforce
that that in this case takes the form of
a legal construct that you're you're not
going to put in the requisite efforts
okay but it just seems to me there's so
much downside that prevents flexibility
how do you how do you think about that
or is there an argument for the legal
construct of marriage because I have
more and more difficulty as I see
friends marriages imploding exploiting
good people often faithful people it
gets harder and harder for me yeah but
Americans love to marry well once or
twice three friends you know part of the
way that I began the project of writing
about infidelity came out of the the
Lewinsky Clinton scandal because I was
very intrigued why was this country so
tolerant about multiple divorces and so
intransigent about the slightest
transgression right
right sure no you know no matter how
much sex becomes open they remain
intransigent about the subject of
infidelity and the rest of the world by
the way that is more family oriented has
always opted the other way around you
will affect the family you know
and you don't divorce so baby I why
Americans love to marry I have never
fully understood I mean I had my
thoughts but it's not like I have a
definitive answer to that I think there
is a two questions there is why do
people could do you know why why is a
deep meaningful connection with another
human being with whom you weave a story
you know along the stages of life that
is one thing does it need to take place
within the construct of marriage is a
very different thing agrees so you know
in Europe we marry much less but we have
families and and we try to create
families with what modernity has given
us which is a rather nuclear model of
family which is a very difficult model
for family and in a terrible model for
couples we were not meant to be two
adults with four or two or three or four
children all alone in cities I mean none
of it is is the way we were meant to do
it and so it's extremely taxing on the
couple and at the same time the only
reason families today survive is if the
couple is doing relatively well right
that's the only thing keeping families
together so we're facing a very
interesting thing at the same time if
Apple sold your product that fails 50%
of the time would you buy it again I
don't have a plan much for her well if
you think that that's a guarantee think
again because at this point it is really
not doing that well in terms of
guaranteeing new things at but I think
they're very few rituals at this moment
you know with the loss of traditional
religion they're very few which was
there very few structures very few
institutions to which we can adhere and
and I can see that in that sense they
had the importance of marriage as as a
ritual that is rooted in a tradition and
that comes with a code of conduct
with an official norm to it and so
that's where I place marriage I don't
think of it in legal terms at all I
think of it very much in terms of its
cultural meaning it's there very few you
know it's like a spine there very few
things people can hang themselves on
these days you know everything is about
the self the and the burdens of the
cells are very heavy at this moment so
marriage has become that that that that
that institution that still tells you
how how to go about doing these things
in life to me the very interesting thing
when you ask about why marry I think
about the gay marriage gay marriage
really was one of the ways to try to
understand what does it mean to legalize
to give rights to queer families to to
allow people to to adhere to a norm when
there are so few norms at this moment
everything has been re-evaluated and
redefined and I think people are
sometimes very desperate for norms
structures where our pillars
architecture you know everything else is
fluid fluid fluid you know but we all
need solid as well as we need fluid and
marriage has remained one of the last
solid constructs even though it
fractures way too fast and way too often
can you do it without marriage
completely I think that you know but for
some reason people feel that commitment
without the structure isn't but rest in
the same way you know the marriage is
the buttress to it's the fulcrum and
I don't know if relationships actually
that would be an interesting thing to
look at numbers do relationships that
are not held together by the contract of
marriage do they dissolve anymore in
Europe than they do here I'm not sure
you know it's fifty two percent or forty
eight at this point maybe to come down a
bit on first marriage but the
fascinating data is not first marriage
it's 65 percent divorce rate on second
marriages 65 percent yeah that is a much
more interesting data yeah why yeah why
why do you find it interesting because
it touches on something else that I
think is much more interesting as a
family as a couple therapist is that
okay let's assume the second time it's
easier you've done it the first time you
may not have the young children it's a
data but to me the more interesting
thing is that the first time you still
actually adhere to the model you know I
think that often the divorces are the
true idealists they believe in the model
they just chose the wrong person and
they do better next time
the second time they begin to think that
maybe it's not all about the other
person and that maybe it's time to take
some responsibility for themselves
everybody at some point has some
relationship things to work out and the
only question is with whom who are you
going to do it with but it would seem
that at some point you should also ask
wait a second if if the if the people
are coming out of the same factory
meaning the structure that has a 50
percent failure rate perhaps you did the
structure should also be a comparable
under consideration I would think
absolutely but that's coupledom that's
not that's not just marriage as my sure
identify dress no I think that to me I'm
really fascinated by how creative you
know having just written a book about
infidelity I can tell you if people took
you know 1% of the creativity that they
put in their affairs and brought it to
their marriages or to go
you know it's astounding it's the same
people change context and they suddenly
are filled with imagination and
attention and focus and generosity and
kindness and desires like you know so
it's not marriage per se as coupledom
and for some reasons the expectations of
coupledom and never have been higher but
what people invest in it hasn't really
measured up between the best of
themselves not to their partner they
bring the best of themselves at work to
their friends to their colleagues to
their to their hobbies their children
for that matter much more not to their
partner and that is a much more
interesting thing to me than marriage
per se it's like I don't ask so much why
do people marry I ask more why do people
so often bring the leftovers to their
partner while at the same time wanting
their relationships to be so glorious
something doesn't click what do you
think the answer is you know it's like
when people say my father is my best
friend and I'm sometimes especially in
my office I have to say do you treat
your best friend like this ha ha ha ha
because what kind of BS is this I mean
no no that's not how you know would you
say this to somebody else could you
imagine being that critical with your
friends what is the idea this is where
marriage comes in it's because you
really think that because you married
the other person is just going to be
there and take it vice versa this is in
both directions right like that that
there is something about the seal at
underneath that has locked this that
allows people to then behave sub car
right and maybe there was more of a fear
that of losing it because your friends
won't take it certainly your boss won't
take it your colleagues won't take it
you behave that way I'd work you out but
at home you think you can do these
things you can treat people really
poorly you can put them down
you can disqualify them you cannot
listen to them you can shout you can
kick you can
neglect them you can be indifferent I
mean my god there is so many ways to not
behave well at home and and then call
them you know it's like to me this is
what I call people that make people
accountable it's like excuse me excuse
me you can't trap another person this is
like you know marital sadism so you have
we get our four hours and you have a
number of different venues and vehicles
through which you're exploring these
topics the book is one of course and
what did you say the title of new book
one more time please
so the book is the state of affairs
rethinking infidelity so I suspect that
will be as your talks and previous work
has been very very popular and topical
and yes I would say this I would say why
do people cheat why do happy people
cheat is infidelity always a deal
breaker why do we think that men need
variety and our board and whereas we
think that women are hungry for intimacy
and lonely why do we have such complete
different ideas about why men and women
cheat what do we do with jealousy can
love ever be plural its possessiveness
and arcane vestige of patriarchy or is
it intrinsic to love tell these
questions that I'm taking on and you're
also going to be exploring that in your
own program on an audible channel soon
as I understand it yeah and yeah if you
wouldn't mind describing that a little
bit yes I'm very excited about I mean
it's really different ways of exploring
you know the book the state of affairs
is not really a book about infidelity
it's really a book about what do we
learn from infidelity about the human
heart and the human condition so I use
that lens to enter into excavate you
know many many subjects and I wanted to
also have you know the opportunity of
letting people come into my office and
actually
in those conversations that I have with
couples because most of the time we have
no idea what happens in a couple you
know couples are isolated islands
sometimes the women may talk to somebody
and the men talk to very few and so we
have no idea what's in the antechamber
you know of the couple na so I did a
series with audible and we're going to
do a second one already that of ten
couples therapy sessions covering a
range of subjects where you think you
are actually entering into the intimacy
of these other relationships and you
very quickly realize that you're
actually looking inside in you're
looking at your own mirror and you're
looking at yourself and and you start to
talk with the persons the people of your
life your partners or others about where
you are in relation to these questions
so then there are stories of infidelity
and stories of sexuality and stories of
raising children and stories of of
infertility and stories of unemployment
and and it's a it's a very very poignant
experience because it's intimate in your
ear you don't see them but you hear them
10 couples who have volunteered to come
and have a session with me like I do
generally in my office it's exactly what
I would normally do but this time
recorded and told as to as stories to
share and stories to invest ourselves in
what is the name of the series where
should we begin where should we begin
that's what everything is I did where
should we begin so there only and for
people listening in the show notes I
will have links to everything that I can
get links to that we've discussed
podcast comes out May 18 and at first it
will be inaudible and on Amazon Prime
and then the book comes out in September
we'll be in stores October 10 and then
the podcast will also be released on
iTunes and so it will be released
at the same time as the book comes out
so I have just a few more questions I
want to let you get back to your day but
but just as we wrap up a few quick
questions
one is what books besides your own have
you gifted the most to other people or
the book after the gifted the most is
Viktor Frankl the search for meaning hmm
very since I'm 16 as a fantastic book
and what about reread the most yourself
what book have you reread or books
anything that any books that come to
mind you've reread I recently reread the
art of loving by Erich Fromm I reread
the erotic mind by Jack Morin I reread
oh I reread for this book I reread
Madame Bovary which was very
disappointing how I'll tell you what I
reread that I loved because one of my
kids was reading it in school Crime and
Punishment now you can have reread the
Russians that that we just I don't they
are timeless and if you had a billboard
this is a metaphoric question but if you
had a huge billboard where you could put
a short message on it non-commercial but
a short message up could be one word
could be a sentence could be whatever to
get out to millions of people what would
you put on that billboard or what might
you put on that billboard there's always
more you can do for another do something
for the you know just don't have your
day without having done something for
someone that you don't know for that
matter not just for the ones that are in
your little circle
and a billboard it would say do do your
part I love it and any any parting
comments requests of the audience could
be the same thing they just said but are
any any parting thoughts questions or
suggestions for people who are listening
any any ask of the audience you know the
reason I see do you part is because so
much of the culture we live in is about
doing things for ourselves
enhancing ourselves pushing ourselves
being more successful being more healthy
you know and it is the most powerful
antidepressants I know yet you do
something on the depression front as
well and I I think that the curse of
today's isolation there's a lot of other
things we have gained but we have lost
something and isolation and this
connection is really is a curse it's a
curse of modern life and I think that
there is no more powerful antidepressant
and no nothing that will give us more
meaning in life than to know that we
matter for others and that means to do
for others which is a little bit what
couples therapy is about you know most
of the time people come together sappy
they don't come in order to say I came
to check myself out they usually come to
be an expert on the other and they say
fix it do something you know or I came
to drop off you know so I'm all the time
thinking you know and what are you doing
take responsibility you know it's
freedom responsibility and for the rest
it's like if any of you are inspired by
what I say join me on all the platforms
where you can find me so easily and and
there's nothing I think I value more
than to be in conversation like I've so
enjoyed our conversation you and I and
to talk about these things it's it's
part of everybody's life all the time
love sex trust loyalty commitment what
else is there you know absolutely a
where is the best place on social media
for people to say hello to you if they
wanted to say hello
so any any one preferred place I would
see my fanpage on Facebook probably but
I am on Twitter and I'm an Instagram and
I'm on YouTube I'm doing this whole
beautiful series actually of videos that
I'm putting up on YouTube on relational
intelligence that I think kind of a
snapshots of what I I when I say in
short what I often say long I'll tell
you what I want is we we have often
these days try to simplify things and I
think what I try to do is create a
conversation and on relationships and
love and all of that I'd work as well as
at home both levels of relationships in
business in companies etc that embraces
complexity that's multicultural and
that's inclusive and I think that the
more people join this the more I will
you will help me do my piece of social
change mm-hmm so everybody definitely
say hello to Esther Esther Perel on
Facebook Instagram Esther Perel official
YouTube / l Esther switch now put all of
these in the show notes Esther thank you
so much for taking the time this is a
real joy and a tremendous tremendously
stimulating and thought-provoking you
have a lot - a lot to think on so I
appreciate you sharing your expertise
and your experiences with us thank you
so treat thanks a lot
and to everybody listening you can find
links to everything that has been
mentioned the the books the podcast
everything imaginable in the show notes
as usual with every other episode you
can just go to tim dot blog forward
slash podcast and until next time thank
you for listening hey guys this is Tim
again just a few more things before you
take off number one this is five bullet
Friday do you want to get a short email
from me would you enjoy getting a short
email for me every Friday is that
provides a little morsel of fun for the
weekend and 500 Friday is a very short
where I share the coolest things I've
found or that I've been pondering over
the week that could include favorite new
albums that I've discovered it could
include gizmos and gadgets and all sorts
of weird [ __ ] that I've somehow dug up
in the the world of the esoteric as I do
it could include favorite articles that
I have read and that I've shared with my
close friends for instance and it's very
short it's just a little tiny bite of
goodness before you head off for the
weekend so if you want to receive that
check it out just go to 4-hour workweek
dot-com that's 4-hour workweek com all
spelled out and just drop in your email
and you will get the very next one and
if you sign up I hope you enjoy it
this episode is brought to you by
audible which I have used for many many
years I absolutely love audiobooks and
they are one of my favorite ways to pass
the time when I travel I'm on the road
all the time and audible allows me to
consume many more books than I possibly
could otherwise I have two audio books
to recommend right off the bat the first
is perhaps my favorite audio book of all
time and it's the only audio book I've
wanted to listen to twice in a row the
graveyard book by Neil Gaiman it's
amazing
annual thank you there are a few
different versions I like the version
that Neil narrates himself one of the
most soothing voices of all time the
second book is vagabonding by Ralph
Hawks Pio tts which had a huge impact on
my life and formed the basis for a lot
of what would later become the 4-hour
workweek so go to audible.com for word
slash Tim and you can choose one of
these two books or any of many many
other options back of the books
magazines and much more as a listener of
the Tim Ferriss show you can also access
a free 30-day trial just go to
audible.com forward slash Tim you can't
make more time but you can make the most
of it so turn your travel or your
commute into something more with a free
trial at audible.com forward slash Tim
to start now and get your free 30-day
trial this podcast is brought to you by
4 Sigma tech I reached out to these
Finnish folks young entrepreneurs very
talented after a Acrobat introduced me
to one of their products
which is mushroom coffee this specific
one includes chaga and lion's mane and
not my socks off I highly recommend if
you try it you start with half a packet
it's very strong and lights you up like
a Christmas tree in the best way
possible people are always asking me
what I use for cognitive enhancement and
for right now this is the answer I try
to force this on all of my house gets it
is a hell of a thing if I have employees
or people come over who are working on
projects with me I always try to feed it
to them because I'm going to get the
limitless effect it gets a lot more out
of them the first time I mentioned this
product and for sig Matic on the podcast
your products sold out in less than a
week so you may want to check them out
soon if you're listening to this and the
coffee tastes like coffee
it takes just seconds to prepare with
hot water and oddly enough only includes
40 milligrams of caffeine so it has less
than half of what you'd get in a regular
cup of coffee I don't get any jitters
acid reflux or any stomach burn any of
that it's very unusual and very very
cool so if you don't like caffeine they
also offer very strong but caffeine free
mushroom elixirs which I will sometimes
have in the evening I find chaga
specifically to be very very grounding
and earthy so that is another option and
I have a cupboard full of their products
at the moment which is right around the
corner in my kitchen you can try
something you can try a sample pack
which is great also right now by going
to four sig Matic calm forward slash Tim
that's for sig Matic fo you are SI GM
ATI c.com /e Tim and use the code tim TI
m to get 20% off of your first order and
they're not that expensive anyway if you
are in the experimental mindset I do not
think you'll be disappointed to try them
you
[Applause]